non je vais simplement dit qu'il avait
fait une très belle campagne qui l'avait
rendu de la noblesse et de la dignité à
la politique on a eu une campagne
marquée en fait à la fois par cette
campagne en faveur du vote utile et puis
également par les affaires en fait qui
ont empêché qu'il ya un vrai débat de
fond
mes chers compatriotes
on m'avait porté au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
j'en mesure l'honneur avec humilité et
reconnaissance je voudrais vous exprimer
à vous électeurs patriotes français
ma plus profonde gratitude la première
étape qui doit conduire les français à
l'elysée est franchie ce résultat est
historique il fait reposer sur moi
désormais la responsabilité immense de
la défense de la nation française de son
unité de sa sécurité dans sa culture de
sa prospérité et de son indépendance
il interprète également comme un acte de
fierté française celui d'un peuple qui
relève la tête
celui d'un peuple sûre de ses valeurs et
confiant en l'avenir
il n'a échappé à aucun français que le
système a cherché par tous les moyens
même les plus contestables a étouffé le
grand débat politique qu aurait dû être
cette élection ce grand débat va
maintenant enfin avoir lieu
les français doivent saisir cette
opportunité historique qui s'ouvre car
le grand enjeu de cette élection est la
mondialisation sauvage qui met en danger
notre civilisation
les français ont un choix très simple
soit nous continuons sur la voie d'une
dérégulation totale sans frontières et
sans protection avec comme conséquence
les délocalisations la concurrence
internationale déloyale l'immigration de
masse
la libre circulation des terroristes ce
règne c'est celui de l'argent roi
soit vous choisissez la france des
frontières qui protège nos emplois notre
pouvoir d'achat
notre sécurité notre identité nationale
vous avez donc le choix de l'alternance
la vraie pas celle qui a vu des
gouvernements se succéder sans que rien
ne change
celle que je vous propose c'est la
grande alternance l'alternance
fondamentale qui mettra en place une
autre politique d'autres visages au
pouvoir et le renouvellement auquel vous
aspirez ce n'est évidemment pas avec
l'héritier de françois hollande et de
tous les échecs de ce quinquennat
catastrophique
non ce tant attendu viendra il tente
désormais de libérer le peuple français
tout le peuple sans oublier nos
compatriotes d'outre-mer qui ont exprimé
à mon égard une confiance qui m'honore
il est temps de libérer le peuple
français des leads arrogance qui veulent
lui dicter sa conduite car oui je suis
la candidate du peuple
je lance un appel à tous les patriotes
sincères d'où qu'ils viennent
quelles que soient leurs origines
quelles qu'aient été leurs parcours et
leurs votes au premier tour à me
rejoindre
je les appelle à sortir des querelles
périmés des a priori et des
ressentiments parce qu'il y va de
l'intérêt supérieur du pays
c'est l'essentiel vraiment l'essentiel
qui est en jeu la survie de la france je
les appelle à l'unité nationale
derrière notre projet de redressement
nous et nous les accueillerons
paternellement 8 août 1943 le général de
gaulle le rappelait à casablanca la
grandeur d'un peuple ne procède que de
ce peuple
c'est ce principe qui durant les 1500
ans de son histoire a façonné la france
que nous aimons c'est ce principe que je
mettrai en oeuvre au rassemblement du
peuple français auquel chacun aspire ne
peut se faire que tour de l'amour de la
france
vive le peuple français vive la
république vive la france
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour cette déclaration de marine
le pen vous avez pu suivre en direct sur
les chaînes parlementaires